[Musique]
cette loi permet et c'est la volonté du
sénat avant tout de fiabiliser
juridiquement la concession de la cnr
pour lui éviter tout recours tout
recours derrière il y as voit le
rappeler trois enjeux autour de la
compagnie du rhum sans doute le premier
le principal c'est celui de produire de
l'électricité
au travers de l'hydro électricité mais
aussi un enjeu
agricole qui permet l'irrigation et du
coup une dynamique agricole dans ce
territoire et puis un enjeu de
navigation sur le rhône le rappeler que
le rhône prend sa source en suisse au
pied d'un glacier pour aller jusqu à
marseille et que c'est un enjeu de
territoire très très très fort dans tous
les atouts qu'on peut qu on peut
souligner il ya celui du du montage où
il ya l'état les que les collectivités
les territoires qui sont à l'intérieur
du capital avec le privé ce montage là
il a fait ses preuves il a fait ses
preuves et encore une fois il il reste
très très local sur ce territoire là
donc c'est une production française
produite sur un fleuve qui est un cas
une belle histoire
[Musique]
c'est une vraie histoire en france un
l'hydroélectricité c'est une
production d'électricité complètement
renouvelables qui dégage pas d'émissions
qui est stockables ce qui est très très
rare dans les énergies renouvelables
donc il ya plein de bienfaits à
l'hydroélectricité néanmoins on a
souhaité notamment au sénat pousser un
peu plus loin en incitant au travers de
nos travaux la compagnie du rona à
s'investir encore plus dans le
photovoltaïque innovant et également sur
l'hydrogène l'hydrogène vers bas carbone
ou là il y a un fort consensus européen
une vraie volonté une vraie stratégie et
qu'une belle entreprise comme ça qu'un
territoire comme celui là qu'à une
histoire dans la production d'énergies
renouvelables puissent y investir est
sans doute une très très bonne chose